what's going on guys today my girlfriend
who knows nothing about anime is going
to be guessing the quirks and hero names
of different mighty academia characters
and after she's made our guesses i'll
explain what powers they actually have
and we can see how close she was to the
right answer
so around last year we did this concept
and just for the people watching can you
tell everyone how much anime or manga
you've read or watched since then
there was that one
that
was annoying me the one where it was the
same sort of like episode concept oh
george has been our adventure yeah yeah
yeah okay
to be fair you did passively watch that
a bit but when it comes to my hero you
basically know nothing is that right no
i no nothing literally nothing yeah all
right so we're gonna start off the first
quirk on this list
let's start off with this character here
so just tell me what you think his quirk
might be and also what you think his his
hero name is or villain name if you
think he's evil
um so i've seen this character before
meg the stallion got the same hairstyle
as this one she has a wig where it's
like those two split colors but i don't
i don't know anything else
was there anything in her cosplay that
like
gave you a hint to what it might be i
just remember the wig if i'm honest i
don't remember anything else okay fair
enough so
the quirk
is i is it something to do with his eye
because he's i think it might be
something to do with his eye okay
because his eyes are different colors
okay and is that a birth mark of some
sort so i see a birthmark
obviously his hair is like half and half
i'm thinking that's to do with like his
like sense of morality you know like
you know 50 50. obviously it's red and
white so like you know his purity versus
like his evilness oh that's quite cool
actually i like that so i like to think
that maybe he's like an anti-hero at
times okay kind of like loki
um
oh he looks like he's got like bombs or
some sort of canisters trapped around
his waist i feel like his arm things
also may be playing to his power
and it looks like he's got like ammo and
stuff around him so i'm gonna say that
his quirk is like um yeah his quirk is
just being like a super soldier
i like like captain america or something
i know and his name so he doesn't look
like mystical or like you know that he
has like a magical magic powers yeah so
i feel like he'd have like a normal name
but every time i say normal names
obviously because it's japanese i never
like go for a hero name hero names
they're not as japanese sounding okay
uh
commander okay we'll go with that we'll
go with commander
okay so
you yeah you were right in the sense
that his hair being two different colors
it does have a meaning it's not about
sense of morality though it's more about
uh on the right hand side where it's
white he has ice powers so from that
side of his body he can shoot out ice
and uh basically generate that and from
his left side of his body he can
generate fire so the name of this quirk
is half hot half cold it's one of the
few hybrid quirks in this series because
if you think about it you know ice and
fire they're kind of like two opposite
things right yeah so yes essentially has
two powers but it's one quirk
okay yeah it's one of the more
overpowered quirks in the series for
sure
what's his name his name is shoto
todoroki oh i've heard you say that
before have you i've heard you say that
yeah yeah he's one of the more prominent
characters in the series um i say you
know besides the the main main main
characters which is deku bakugo and
probably all might he's like just
underneath them in terms of importance
and wait so is he a good guy he's a good
guy yeah he's part of the hero school
okay
okay so moving on to the next character
we have this person oh my god so what
are your first impressions of her
female almighty
yeah
i mean she looks like that yeah
um
what do you think her power might be
captain america type just like strong
yeah we just did that one we just but
that's what she looks like she looks
like she's hella strong look at those
muscles
but i feel like she can fly okay so i
feel like maybe she flies but it's kind
of like she plays up to the cameras
plays up to the media
hey kids it's me you know you learn
about them in schools you know like that
sort of thing
but
i feel like she's not all that good you
know like i feel like it's a complete
front like ah she's just like do i look
good in these cameras are people talking
about me like you know like it's just
i hold a bs yeah so she's not like a
genuine hero she's kind of doing it for
the image exactly exactly like as soon
as the cameras go off like the gringos
they're just like oh i hate kids you
know yeah yeah yeah
um
so you think a quote might be flight
yeah flight strength
okay and in terms of a hero name i'll
give you one hint for a hero name look
at her costume for a second like that if
you just look at a costume you might be
able to guess what the hero name is oh
just from the pattern on it
stripes
close close so i hear your name is star
and stripe ah
okay okay yeah so um in terms of our
quirk it's one of the more newer quirks
that's been added to the series as of
recording this video anyway and her
quirk is called new order so basically
she can touch something and then make a
rule that that thing has to follow oh
yeah so for example she can touch
herself and a rule she made was that she
has super strength and it just happens
it's almost like magic um and so she can
touch the air and make the air disappear
in certain areas or she can touch other
people and if she calls their name out
correctly then she can basically make
them die oh so she's a bad guy no she's
a good guy but uh
one of the one of the good guys who's
more willing to kill i guess okay yeah
so if she was to touch you and call out
your name she could say you know as she
did in the manga she could say your
heart will stop if you move an inch and
then that would happen if she knows your
correct name i say it's one of the top
two most powerful quirks wow
but yeah female all my i i can't
disagree with that description i can't
disagree with that she's also um that
sort of
that quirk reminds me of a wolverine's
girlfriend in
um origins that's what she can do she
can touch people and tell them what to
do yeah yeah i remember that because at
the end of the movie she made that guy
walk for a million miles or something
right that guy yeah yeah
um okay so let's move on to the next one
oh
so what do you think of this person oh
my god they're so cute they're meant to
be like 15 or 16 years old but they look
like a kid yeah
oh that's so cute look at those eyes
they're they're definitely a good person
yeah they're so cute i love the hair
their hair obviously plays a part of
their quirk i think maybe because
they're like covered in it is that their
hair they're covered in or what i don't
know but i think um oh they're just so
cute i think maybe
their quirk is um something to do the
shadows they look like they're in the
dark a bit i think when they no maybe
not shadows invisibility maybe maybe
when their like hair
turns into like their outfit
they they turn invisible okay okay and
uh hearing what do you think that their
hearing aid might be
shadow
okay
okay this is a good guess uh it's not
close at all but it's a good guess
um so
the things on his head they're not hair
they're kind of like these balls and his
quirk is called pop off and basically
whenever he takes these balls off his
head they can stick to things and they
stick really hard so it's really hard to
move them
and he is the only person who the balls
don't stick to so if he was to put a
ball down on the floor he could jump on
it and bounce and it would like send him
flying like a trampoline but for
everyone else they would stick to it and
they wouldn't be able to move
um and when he removes the balls they
grow straight back on his head so that's
why you know he's in these two pitches
he's always got them on his head um but
it's not hair it's just this weird yeah
these weird balls okay and he's a good
guy right he's a good guy yeah trying to
be a hero but he's probably one of the
uh
not one of the best students um in the
class but because he's always focused on
like getting girls basically and always
failing at that but um but yeah
okay he's cute
wait if he asked on a date would you go
no no he's too late he's nice you said
he was cute yeah like oh you're a
child's cute
oh okay
so this character
oh wow okay
first impression what do you think
sleaze bag you know
would absolutely screw you over
the minute you left the room
he looks like the type of person that
just like
does magic for no reason so i imagine
that he has like cards like magic cards
and i i feel like his his
something to do with cards like he can
like
throw like cards at you and they like
have little mini explosions and they
just explode for no reason and like
he'll throw a card up and then he'll
disappear and there'll be like a poof
you know so i feel like his his quirk is
like like magic but like it's going so
fast like the cars can cut you or like
he could just disappear
like he just has like magic cards and
like in his pocket for like no reason
um and his name
mr man
[Laughter]
okay now i can tell you running out of
ideas
um so that quirk idea was actually
really cool i kind of wish that was a
real thing um
this guy's quirk it's called stress i'm
pretty sure it's called stress anyway uh
and basically the idea is that the more
stress he gets he can accumulate that
stress inside of him and then when he
wants to he can use the stress to
basically turn himself into a giant so
he can make his hands supersize he can
make his legs super sized or you just
make his whole body the size of godzilla
or something
and yeah it's basically turning stress
into size
and then when he's big he can also turn
the stress into these these massive like
energy stress balls that kind of like
destroy a whole city if he wants to
one of the top tier villains in terms of
strength uh like raw power but like i
said he has to be stressed out for his
quirk to really be effective what what
type of things would make him stressed
so he's the ceo of a company and i think
that was intentional oh my gosh yeah and
he's a villain he's a villain yeah you
can tell you can so tell
something about like that image on the
left that i put there he does look kind
of sleazy and i can see why you thought
he might have cards because his hands
are behind his back yeah he just looks
like yeah yeah just doing magic like
all the time yeah
okay so
what about this person oh wow
he looks like um
a mean gruff man like
laughs at nothing finds nothing funny
like you look at him he's like do you
look at me you're like no
you know just starting fights
in bars smashing beers
um
he's got he's got like that obviously
ammunition across his chest and i feel
like the glasses might play a part in
his quirk as well
hmm
i'm not sure you know because i feel
like yes he's got ammunition across his
chest but like i don't see any guns or
anything like that and he's got a big
mouth so i feel like maybe he's got like
um
sort of like supersonic sound waves you
know like if he shouts really loud it's
just really loud it makes you like grab
your ears
and like stops you in the moment you
know
yeah so he'll just like go ah you know
and then you just have to grab your ears
and then he can like yeah stop whatever
you're doing and then he can beat you up
and then shoot you and then use his guns
you know what i mean so i feel like he
uses his voice he has like just this
deep like and when he just like roars it
just stops what you're doing you just
can't bear the sound
yeah i like that i guess because there
is actually a character in my academia
who has a quote very similar to what you
just described uh it's not this guy but
um the person who described it is a hero
i need to do his name oh yeah yeah guess
what's his name
um
his hero name is
rory do you get it rory
how did you just come up with that i
don't know
how did you just come up with such a
great part that that is
ridiculous
um
you know if we were doing a point system
i would have given you like 100 points
for that because that's amazing but um
so this guy he is a hero um but his
quirk is more like instead of shouting
he has uh this quirk that's
you know how like spider-man shoots out
webs yeah like he can swing from things
and all that this guy basically does
that exact same thing only he uses these
things called black whips instead
and so the black whips they come out of
his hands and and also technically they
can come out of his mouth as well and he
can use it to swing around basically
like spider-man and he can
trap people with it he can shoot it out
and throw things with it pretty
versatile in that sense um
but this is an interesting piece of
trivia you might not know and that is
i obviously don't know
you know um you know deku
you know you know deku yeah so deku's
quite one for all this guy used to have
it before deku had it oh how did he lose
it so he passed it on to the next person
because one fall is like one of the only
quirks that can be transferred from one
person to one person um so this guy had
it before deku he passed on to someone
else who passed it on someone else who
passed on to all might and then almighty
gave it to deku oh okay so he's one of
like deku's predecessors ah
he seems really pissed that he lost it
yeah i mean he would be pissed because
he got killed by uh all for one he's
like the main bad guy of the series so
yeah he he was pissed
rest in peace rory yeah rest in rest in
peace
what do you think
that that's
horrifying isn't it that face oh my
goodness
he's got swag i like the jacket though
i think his hands must play a part
because he's always got his hands up
oh and then like
i think his
quirk is to do like light and darkness
light darkness shadows so i think that
he can take the light from you and then
put it in himself but he turns it dark
so i think right so he uses those big
hands he like touches you he takes the
light from inside you so he kills you
then he puts it in himself and it turns
it into the darkness that he is and then
his eyes will glow like in the yellow on
the right there
damn
that's like some fantasy novel type
type quirk um
and what do you think his name might be
hmm
dark matter
okay and when you say that he takes the
light is the light like your soul is
that what he's taking yeah your soul
like yourself your your
yeah your being you know what makes you
you he literally takes it from you
and then he
what does he do with that again absorbs
it and it makes him stronger every soul
that he takes every light from someone
he takes it makes him stronger but you
die when he takes it that is dark thanks
yeah that's some dark stuff um
his ability is kind of like this ice
manipulation quirk uh because with his
mind he can manipulate ice in the area
so let's just say there was ice let's
just say there were packs of ice in the
local convenience store he could
manipulate that ice from like 100 meters
away pull it towards him and then
restructure it into like uh these a
giant pair of ice hands maybe or like a
giant ice dragon like he can do whatever
he wants with ice and he'd also control
the temperature of it as well so he can
make ice colder and colder and colder
which in turn might uh if he was to put
the ice in water he could turn that
water into ice so we can just keep on
making making it basically
and he is a villain and did you guess
that i can't remember if you guessed
that or not i mean if he's taking
people's souls and killing them oh good
point good point
good for it
um so what's his name so his name is
getting and he works for you know the
guy who uh had the big nose that we were
talking about a second ago so he works
for that guy right so
like his his henchman yeah yeah
basically like his henchman yeah okay
so the final character of this video is
this person uh so what are your first
impressions of them
cute he reminds me of the guy from squid
game what the main guy from good game no
the one um
oh i know the one you're talking about
the one who was like the uh the
financial guy yeah yeah yeah yeah
so what do you think his quark might be
um i see him running there so he's fast
like the flash fast yeah like just super
fast like yeah flash a train super speed
i don't know why he's so expressive
though but maybe he's got like hella
girls and what do you think his hearing
aid might be
bullet because he's fast like yeah
bullet that is sick that is awesome so
in terms of his quirk you are right and
that it gives him super speed uh he
doesn't quite reach the flash levels
because i'm pretty sure the flash is so
fast he can like go back in time and
stuff
but no this is uh his quirk is pretty
good he has basically exhaust pipes in
his calves he has those in his carbs and
so when he drinks a lot of orange juice
he gets a lot of energy to run super
fast and the exhaust pipes basically
just propelled him forward at super high
speeds so yeah speed is like his main
thing uh and he uses it to kick people
or just run super fast now what else is
there about him i guess he's he's good
yeah he is good he is good um he's a
hero he's on the same course as deck
who's probably he's one of deku's best
friends actually
and uh yeah he has an older brother who
used to be hero as well and so he's kind
of like taking on the mantle of that uh
of his brother and succeeding him as the
hero called ingenium but i think
bullet's actually a cooler name than
that yeah i i agree
and uh yeah like i said he's he's really
just expressive emotional uh but he's
also quite serious as well at times um
because he's like the class rep so he's
always like just basically telling
people what to do and stuff like that
but but it's funny you mention him
getting all the girls although he
doesn't get any girls in the series that
we've seen he is very popular uh in
japan from what i can remember anyway
he's always ranked quite highly in the
japanese like popularity polls um so i
guess the girls in japan love him in
real life
but yeah not too sure about in the show
itself
but yeah that was it um so just before
we end the video where can people find
you on socials if they wanna if they
wanna follow you
i can't even what's my instagram uh
laverne.jpg
jpg
okay awesome awesome and uh yeah thank
you guys for watching this video as
always and don't forget to sub if you
haven't already and until the next one
peace out
bye